in an era marked by religious decline
Mormons appear to be holding their own
1/4 of Americans are religiously
unaffiliated today among young adults
roughly 4 and 10 are now unaffiliated
it's a trend that's affecting nearly
every major religious denomination in
the US with one important exception the
Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints the more in population in the US
has remained steady over the past few
years even while other Christian
denominations have shed members so why
are Mormons faring so well it's all
about family Mormons get married earlier
stayed married longer and have larger
families than members of other Christian
denominations Mormons are also more
likely to marry within their faith than
members of most other religious
traditions eighty-two percent of married
Mormons report that their spouse is also
Mormon we're Mormons family is really
fundamental 81 percent of Mormons
prioritize being a good parent and
nearly three-quarters say that having a
good marriage is one of their most
important life priorities do you think
the decline of religion in the u.s. is a
good thing or bad thing let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AAI